moi en tant que croyant forcément je
suis choqué que ce soit dans une église
une synagogue ou ou deux une mosquée
forcément ça me choque autant croyant
parce que je sais que derrière tout ça
il ya des croyants ça peut aussi heurté
des millions par des milliers de
personnes testées à lui dire ce soir
noires germa moi j'ai juste envie de lui
dire c'est un discours de grand frère
que j'ai envie de l'avoir inclus c'est
pas un discours de ces pas un discours
de deux je vais te mettre une baffe ou
quoi ou quoi non il faut que tu saches
un truc focus en faut que tu saches un
truc benjamin si tu veux visité deux
mosquées étaient toujours bien venues tu
seras toujours le bienvenu mais il ya
des règles à respecter il faut de la
pudeur du respect il humilité tu vois si
tu arrives à avoir ces trois qualités en
toi viens je te prend la main on y va
tous les deux et tu vas voir un petit
peu le monde qui autour du culte ce soit
dans une église ou dans une synagogue si
je peux me permettre monsieur dans une
mosquée moi je suis musulman donc je
t'invite à venir quand tu es dans une
mosquée viens on va ta cure comme des
grands frères peu importe en orientation
sexuelle ne regarde pas ça peu importe à
vie ok nous en laisse à l'extérieur tu
viens tu rentres c'est vraiment le sujet
tu viens tu rentres tu rentres benjamin
on te donne la main ont tout le montre
ce que c'est ce que c'est qu'islam ce
que c'est que les musulmans et c'est pas
forcément ce que tu vois à la télé les
musulmans vivent non non j'ai pas mes
moyens mais moi en tant que qui veut il
s'en fout de la ville et surtout du
respect de la religion et ils sont fous
de tout en fait d'accord que ma chance
et même un bloc plus clair que ça parce
qu'ils allaient me dit aussi que c'était
pas du tout une démarche contre la la la
la
le mot phobie peut-être de l'église
catholique ou d'autres religions
maintenant il se fâche crois que c'est
assez clair ce que tu fais aujourd'hui
c'est tu fait beaucoup de buzz pour
vendre des vidéos qui te font vivre qui
sont des vidéos de toi je leur avais une
idée et ça me dérange pas du tout est ce
que tu veux mais je vois qu'aujourd'hui
pas clairement il ya plus de messages
non c'est donc là aucun but non pas du
tout c'est quoi c'est cool mais le jour
tunisien plateau que je n'ai pas du tout
moi je suis persuadé
le sujet c'est plus seulement la vidéo
et le fait que j'étais enceinte église
je suis et c'est aussi ce qui s'est
passé ensuite et prend du recul sur la
réaction des gens et moi m'a vachement
pointé du doigt pour ce que j'avais fait
on a beaucoup emprunté du doigt le fait
enfin ce que les gens m'avaient fait à
moi ou à ma famille sens que je donne
une posture victimisante ou quoi que ce
soit et c'est comme faire une échelle de
gravité
de la violence ou de la souffrance c'est
grave c'est un souffle la tendance est
fait
alors oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que tu
voyais ça j'ai dû leur
m
incroyable ce que je deviens parce que
là on rigole on l'applaudît à chaque
fois qu'on clash ou base non mais
l'attitude de la baie de la mort né à la
croix parce qu'ils essaient juste de
comprendre
ça c'est la tolérance la non vous êtes
la chine
attend donc un petit peu de moi et ont
énormément
fait chier à toi que tu veux
capable c'est drôle ce que tu fais donc
on obligeait aussi de me reprendre c'est
drôle comme reproche de faire du buzz ou
deux
mais c'est pas moi qui consomme 6 et les
charges et d'avoir son programme faire
du buzz mais de faire du mal à des
percées sarr c'est exactement ça contre
saissac entre proches